十個當充的人大概有八個賠錢收錢
當充到底是賺塊錢還是賠塊錢
新手該不該碰這部片給你全部的答案
嗨 歡迎來到學法
我是魏德
今天就來跟你誠實聊聊當充這件事情
他到底該不該碰又該怎麼碰
這支影片你會學到三個重點
第一 當充到底是什麼
第二 為什麼八成新手會賠錢
第三 到底該不該碰當充
影片最後還會送你一堂免費的當充懸鼓方法
讓你有機會靠正確的步驟
為自己每天增加2000到6000元
甚至上萬元的投資目標
好 我們直接進入第一個重點
一 當充到底是什麼
當充全名叫
當日充銷
意思很簡單
同一檔股票
在同一天之內
買進又賣出
不留到多天
舉個例子你就懂了
假設花十萬塊
買一張100元的股票
十分鐘之後
漲到了103
你馬上賣掉
這一次就賺了3000塊
只用十分鐘
都賺別人一天兩天的薪水
聽起來是不是很爽
而且當充玩起來很刺激了
紅紅綠綠跳來跳去
輸贏幾分鐘內馬上就知道
這種快感有點像在打電動
但很多人一玩就上來
再加上他當天就出清
不用擔心隔天突然冒出什麼壞消息
睡得比較安穩
而且只要付一點費用就好
門檻
NB 也難怪
現在台股大約四分之一的成交量
都是當充貢獻的
做得了非常的多
而且想白一點
當充最吸引人的地方就是
他靠的是技術
不是你口袋有多深
你不用準備幾百萬的本金
只要練成一套方法
他就是一門能夠跟著你一輩子
每天都能夠拿出來用的賺錢技能
這也是為什麼
這麼多人想要把它學起來
但你一定也聽過
當充很危險
十個當充八個賠
那問題來了
到底是當充本身有問題
還是賠錢的那八成
少做了什麼關鍵的事
這就是第二段
要帶你看清楚的
二 為什麼八成新手會賠錢
當充聽起來很美好啊
但現實很無感
根據統計
每十個當充的人
大概就有八個是賠錢收場
主要有四大原因
第一 成本
馬賣股票
每一次都要付兩種錢
給券商的手續費
還要給政府的交易稅
當充一趟來回這些成本
大概就是本金等千分之四上下
聽起來很少 對吧
但你得先漲超過這個成本
才開始真正賺到錢
如果你一天充個五趟 十趟
光是手續費跟稅
就是一筆很可怕的稅資
很多人忙了一天
錢都進了券商跟國庫的口袋
而且當充賺的往往就是
那麼一點點的價差
但成本卻是每一趟
都十大使得再扣
有時候你以為小賺
一扣掉成本 根本是平手
甚至到虧 這點千萬別小看
第二 對手太強
你以為你在跟其他的賞戶比
其實盤面上很多單
是大護養的 電腦城市
在自動下單
你按一按滑鼠的時間
它已經完成了幾百次的買賣了
賞戶不管是資訊還是速度都輸
有點像是拿菜刀
去跟人家的機關槍對打
第三 也是最難的紀律
當從超級考驗人心
你原本想好 剩兩%就跑
結果他太長一%
就會開始緊張怕跌回去
但最先賣掉
結果還會少賺大多
反過來賠錢的時候
明明想好賠兩%
就要停水賣掉
真的賠到了卻一直跟自己說
再撐一下
等他躺回來
最後一路包包
包到收盤
小賠變成大賠
只要沒有紀律
你就會一直在跟自己的分析對準
第四
超級大敵人
違約交割
如果你買了
超過自己付的錢
當天又沒賣掉
等到付錢時付頭不夠
就叫做違約交隔
比如說
你互同裡面只要10萬塊
你卻下單買了100萬
結果股票跌停賣不掉
你就得在兩天內
伸出那100萬
伸不出來
你單純沒錢
會留下嚴重你的信用
一點正式會被迫跌當中
還有這裡
你可能有點怕
但我要你換個角度想想
這四件事
有哪一個是無解的嗎
成本可以靠控制次數來審
對手可以靠跟對方向來避開
紀律可以靠一套
明確的規則練出來
違約交隔
更是只要短規矩就完全不會發生
換句話說
賠錢的真正原因
從來不是當充太可怕
而是那八成的人
根本沒有人好好教過他們
怎麼正確的做法
三 那新手到底該不該碰
聽到這裡
你可能會以為
我叫你完全別碰
但其實不是
因為當充本身只是一個工具
它沒有好壞
那為什麼還是有人能看他賺錢
因為能穩定賺的
多半是累積了很多年的經驗
有方法 有紀律
來工具跟資源的人
換句話說
賠錢的從來不是當充
而是沒準備就上場的人
那如果你真的想試
至少先做好三件事
第一 先用一筆就算賠光
也不影響你生活的小錢去練習
第二 每次進場前
先設好聽尊典
絕不凹的
第三 把每筆交易記下來
事後檢討自己為什麼賺錢
又為什麼賠錢
另外還有一個很重要的觀念
叫做資金控管
意思就是
就算你再有把握
單筆也別壓得太重
這樣萬一看錯
一次的虧損才不會傷到元氣
你也才有本錢留在股市裡
繼續學 繼續練
賠錢跟賺錢差的往往不是聰明
也不是運氣
而是有沒有一套驗證過的方法
加上做得到的機率
而這兩樣東西就可以學了
也可以練出來的
想像一下
當你也練成了那套方法跟機率
當初對你來說就不再是賭運氣
而是一個能靠自己的判斷
慢慢把收入累積起來的技能
這才是真正值得你花時間學起來的
也正因為這樣
我停費了一堂
免費的
線上當充對稱
請了一位實戰派老師
把建出場的訊號
還有停損的紀律
一步一步
帶你去
讓你不用自己一個人
摸索
少走好幾年的年貌
這堂線上當充對稱
還去免費
報名連結
已經放在下方資訊
或是首頁上面的連結
現在就點擊報名
學會用
方法做的當初
我是魏等
我們下部影片見了
掰掰